[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend der Reflex ist
schnell da bei Politikern wie bei Medien
ein Flüchtlingsboot mit wohl über 700
Menschen kennt hat über 70 werden tot
geborgen etliche werden noch vermisst
und schon gehen die Banden und
Berichterstattung los aber zur Wahrheit
gehört das fast jeden Tag Menschen im
Mittelmeer sterben natürlich nicht in
dieser Dimension nur das wird halt kaum
noch wahrgenommen das Unglück jetzt
erfährt aber auch deshalb so große
Aufmerksamkeit weil der vor einer Woche
gefundene Asylkompromiss auf EU-Ebene
durch die Tragödie noch mal unter die
Lupe genommen wird und wenn man genauer
hinschaut dann scheint der Kompromiss
nur eine Beruhigungspille aber keine
Lösung zu sein ultra und Julia rech
die Akropolis in Athen die Wiege der
europäischen Kultur die Fahne weht auf
Halbmast und eine Frage drängt sich auf
hätten die Flüchtlinge gerettet werden
können
Griechenlands Küstenwache hatte ein Foto
vom Flüchtlingsboot gemacht wie es im
Mittelmeer herumtrieb aber konnte oder
wollte nicht eingreifen das Boot sank
eine Katastrophe die Seenotretter nicht
überrascht
was schaut weg diese bootsunglücke sind
vorprogrammiert sie sind absolut zu
erwarten gewesen mit dem Schiff SOS
humanity retten Till rummenohl und seine
Mannschaft auf dem Mittelmeer
Flüchtlinge seit Jahren schränkt Europa
die Seenotrettung ein konzentriert sich
nur auf Grenzkontrollen
finanziert
mittlerweile aufzugreifen und sie wieder
völkerrechtswidrig nach Libyen zurück zu
schleppen
Europa am Pranger die EU arbeitet an
einem neuen Asylsystem Kernpunkte
härtere Kontrollen an den Außengrenzen
und Verhandlungen mit Transitländern um
die Flüchtlingsströme einzudämmen die
Fragen nach humanenlösungen drängen
wird ursula von der leihen bei den
Regierungen der Transitländer Druck
aufbauen und so versuchen das Leben von
Kindern von Frauen und Männern zu retten
wir arbeiten an wirksamen Lösungen haben
wir sie schon eindeutig nein
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
war vor kurzem beim tunesischen
Präsidenten die EU verspricht Geld dafür
soll Tunesien Schlepperbanden aufhalten
Europas Gesicht hat sich den letzten
zehn Jahren sehr verändert weniger
Willkommenskultur dafür mehr Abschottung
weniger offene Arme dafür mehr Zäune in
der Europäischen Union haben wir unter
Ministern die für Migration zuständig
sind eine Kompromiss auf sehr niedrigem
Niveau was Fährte in der Europäischen
Union angeht gefunden ein Kompromiss auf
niedrigem Werte Niveau auch wenn es
keiner so laut sagt das hat auch mit dem
Aufstieg der rechtsopolisten zu tun in
Polen und Ungarn sitzen sie in den
Regierungen in anderen Ländern wachsen
sie in der Opposition Europa fürchtet
auch um seinen inneren Frieden Europa
hat bewiesen mit den über 4 Millionen
die wir aufgenommen haben aus der
Ukraine dass es auch anders geht und wir
dürfen doch in Europa nicht den
Unterschied machen zwischen Menschen die
eine gewisse die eine Religion haben die
uns vielleicht dann eher passt als
Menschen die aus dem Süden kommen dann
Religion haben die uns vielleicht nicht
so passt die Katastrophe vor Europas
Küste zwingt die EU hinzuschauen Zäune
allein reichen nicht aus um diesen
Anblick zu verhindern
über den gefundenen Asylkompromiss der
EU aber auch über das Bootsunglück mit
bisher über 70 Toten und noch 500
vermissten Menschen möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit dem migrationsexperten und
Politikberater Gerald Knaus der unter
anderem den flüchtlingsstil von 2016 mit
der Türkei für die Bundesregierung mit
ausgearbeitet hat und damit einen
schönen guten Abend nach Wien Herr Knaus
guten Abend hätte der
eu-asylkompromiss wenn er denn jetzt
schon greifen würde dieses Bootsunglück
verhindert
eine sehr klare Antwort nein denn weder
die Zahl der irregulär kommenden noch
die Verpflichtung von Staaten
ihrer seenotrettungspflichten
nachzukommen noch die Verwandlung eines
Tatorts
EU-Außengrenze wo ständig Recht
gebrochen wird in einen Raum der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit keines von diesen
Problemen hätte dieser Kompromiss gelöst
und auch weil ja die Reform vorsieht das
geflüchtete dort geprüft werden wo sie
stranden und nicht dort wo sie starten
also müsste man vielleicht nicht doch an
der afrikanischen Küste prüfen und
entscheiden
also wir brauchen zwei Dinge und es ist
ja
herzzerreißend immer wieder die
Geschichten zu hören dass viele auf
diesen boten Menschen sind die Verwandte
haben als im Februar bei Kalabrien ein
Boot unterging und auch ganz viele
Menschen ums Leben kamen da wurden dann
viele das Särge nach Deutschland
geschickt weil eben die Verwandten
dieser
Opfer in Deutschland waren also man
müsste tatsächlich Wege finden dass
Menschen die zum Teil viel zu lange auf
Familienzusammenführung warten einen
legalen Weg finden einerseits und
andererseits müsste man Menschen
entmutigen die aus anderen Gründen ohne
aber schutzbedürftig zu sein
sich auf den Weg machen und da braucht
man Maßnahmen mit Rückführungen in
sichere Staaten durch
migrationsdiplomatie weiter zusehen darf
man nicht also das was ich gerade
gefragt habe kommt für sie dann nicht
unbedingt infrage bleiben wir noch mal
bei den Außengrenzen die starten an der
EU-Außengrenze also Italien Griechenland
Spanien sind ja jetzt schon verpflichtet
dass sie als
ersteinreiseland Asylverfahren
durchführen das sogenannte
Dublin-Verfahren ist das was ändert sich
eigentlich durch diesen neuen Kompromiss
außer dass ich jetzt starten wie zum
Beispiel Ungarn von der Aufnahme
geflüchteter quasi frei kaufen können
ja die Ungarn werden wahrscheinlich gar
nichts zahlen und sehen das als
willkommene Gelegenheit für einen Streit
mit Brüssel aber für Italien für
Griechenland für Spanien ändert sich
dadurch eigentlich nicht und das ist ja
leicht nachzuvollziehen im letzten Jahr
kamen 55.000 Ägypter Tunesien
bangladeschi ist nach Italien
zurückgeführt werden im Jahr im
Durchschnitt weniger als 2000 der
Menschen aus diesen Ländern die meisten
bekommen keinen Schutz wenn man also
jetzt sagt wir machen für alle ein
verpflichtendes grenzverfahren am Tag
nach dem Abschluss des grenzverfahren
weiß Italien immer noch nicht was mit
den Menschen passieren soll Italien wird
also diese grenzverfahren mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit gar nicht machen wenn
sie sagen diese Menschen bekommen keinen
Schutz damit haben sie natürlich im
Grunde auch kein Recht darauf nach
Europa quasi einzureisen jetzt soll ja
und das ist schon eine Veränderung alles
schneller geben heißt es jedenfalls auf
dem Papier grenzverfahren sondern noch
wenige Wochen dauern und wer nicht
schutzbedürftig ist der muss dann
tatsächlich zurück aber das mit diesem
zurück das klappt ja jetzt schon nicht
wirklich gut wird das denn durch diesen
Kompromiss besser
auch das nicht diese Frage wird gar
nicht adressiert und das große Problem
bei schnellen qualitätsvollen Verfahren
ist das ist immer eine Frage der
Ressourcen wie viele Menschen stehen zur
Verfügung wie viel Übersetzer gibt es
und wie viele Menschen stellen einen
Antrag und das ist nicht die Frage ob
das in den Niederlanden in Frankreich
oder an der Grenze stattfindet sondern
ob die Ressourcen da sind um Qualität zu
sichern die werden wahrscheinlich fehlen
das große Problem ist dass die
Familienzusammenführung die Menschen
einen Anlass gibt sich auf den Weg zu
machen um zu ihren Lieben zu kommen dass
dieser lange dauert das ist kaum legale
Wege für Flüchtlinge gibt und
gleichzeitig dass wir bei denen die
keinen Schutz in der EU brauchen
tatsächlich wie sie sagen keinen
Fortschritt oder bei den Rückführungen
machen weil uns die Partner auf der
anderen Seite des Mittelmeeres fehlen
also wenn ich das jetzt mal
zusammenfasse dann sind das alte
Probleme im Grunde nur neu verpackt oder
hat sich durch den eu-kompromiss denn
irgendetwas für geflüchtete oder für die
aufnehmenden Staaten oder für die
Bundesländer oder die Kommunen
verbessern
ich höre immer dass es hier darum geht
pragmatische Lösungen zu finden
europäische Lösungen aber das ist keine
pragmatische Lösung und ich glaube alle
Staaten die das verhandelt haben schauen
sich das jetzt genau an und werden
erkennen dass es ihnen nichts nützt und
zwar wieder Deutschland nach Italien
wieder Griechenland noch Polen wir
brauchen wirklich etwas besseres und das
brauchen wir so schnell wie möglich um
das Sterben im Mittelmeer zu beenden es
gibt ja immer mehr kriege immer mehr
Krisen immer mehr Katastrophen aber kaum
Lösung jetzt ist der gefundene
Kompromiss in ihren Augen auch keiner
was muss denn passieren außer die zwei
Punkte die sich schon angesprochen haben
wir brauchen dringend
migrationsdiplomatie wir brauchen
Bewegung auf allen Seiten es ist
sinnvoll wenn die cdu/csu die Regierung
unterstützt dabei Menschen die eine
Verbindung zu Deutschland haben legal
ins Land zu holen und nicht gegen
Aufnahmeprogrammen zu stimmen es ist
aber auch sinnvoll wenn die
Ampelkoalition sich nicht gegen das
Prinzip sicherer drittstaatenwert denn
wenn Sie sicher wären und Leute dorthin
geschickt werden könnten könnte das zu
weniger Toten führen wir brauchen mehr
Pragmatismus und wir brauchen
Koalitionen in Europa die ähnliche
Interessen haben und die dann Lösungen
finden die erstens umsetzbar sind
zweitens die Zahl der irregulär
kommenden reduzieren aber drittens das
im Einklang machen mit den
rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien auf die
Europa eigentlich stolz sein sollte also
das Leid an den Außengrenzen beenden da
steht so im Koalitionsvertrag
kollektionsvertrag ob die neue Einigung
dazu beiträgt wenn ich Ihre Antworten
zusammenfasse ist das ein klares Nein
Gerald Knaus vielen Dank für das
Gespräch
danke Ihnen
und das haben wir am frühen Abend
aufgezeichnet aber echte Lösungen ich
glaube dass es gerade klar geworden
müssen her denn das Thema geflüchtete
ist eines dass die Menschen ja bewegt
bis frustriert schauen wir auf die
aktuellen Zahlen des politbarometers und
da meinen aktuell 45% der Befragten dass
Deutschland die Flüchtlinge aus
Krisengebieten verkraften kann 52
Prozent sagen Deutschland verkraftet sie
nicht mit dem ungelösten Thema Asyl aber
auch mit der Unzufriedenheit bzw
Diskussionen rund um das Gebäude
Energiegesetz erklären sich ja viele das
aktuelle Erstaunen der AFD schauen wir
auch da auf die zahlen wenn am nächsten
Sonntag Bundestagswahl wäre dann käme
die SPD auf 19%, die cdu/csu auf 28 die
Grünen legen bei 16 die FDP käme auf 6
und die AFD auf ihren bisher höchsten
Wert von 18 Prozent die Linke auf 5%,
die Ampelkoalition hätte damit also
weiterhin keine parlamentarische
Mehrheit
das dürfte der CDU gefallen nicht
gefallen dürfte ihr das Erstarken der
AFD vor fünf Jahren sprach Friedrich
Merz noch davon dass man die AFD
halbieren können heute nahm er nicht mal
das Wort AFD in den Mund vom kleinen
Parteitag der CDU in Berlin mattes
Feldhoff
Friedrich Merz ist mit sich ganz
zufrieden er hat gekackert in seiner
Rede doch vom halbieren der AFD spricht
er schon länger nicht mehr die CDU wird
ratlos im Umgang mit den Rechtsaußen der
hilft auch selbst Zufriedenheit kaum
weiter doch wie lautet die Antwort auf
18% AFD jedenfalls nicht sich mit ihr
gemein machen März wiederholt die klare
Abgrenzung ich sage das haben die
Adresse der Wählerinnen und Wähler die
vielleicht glauben die Union damit unter
Druck setzen zu können so nach dem Motto
schaut doch mal und addiert doch mal
dann passt es doch nein es passt nicht
nicht einmal in der die AFD beim Namen
aber mehr als um die 30% Zustimmung zur
Union wollen in letzter Zeit einfach
nicht zusammenkommen gerade aus dem
Osten kommt wenn auch vorsichtig
formuliert Kritik am Kurs der
bundesspitzen die Menschen sagen mir an
den Ständen wir hören von euch noch zu
wenig wir können uns hier keine
Worthülsen mehr leisten gestern Abend im
Kreis Görlitz im Kloster Mariental
trifft sich die örtliche CDU hier hat
man jede Menge Erfahrungen im Umgang mit
der AFD bei zwei Bundestagswahlen haben
ihre Direktkandidaten gegen die
rechtsaußenpartei verloren die Debatten
in Berlin werden oft als weltfremd
wahrgenommen
dass man sich vielleicht auch in
politischen Diskussionen verliert die
abgehoben sind von dem was unsere
Realität im Alltag ist und die den
Nachbarn meinen Nachbarn zum Beispiel
eben überhaupt nie bewegen wer das Land
gestalten will und wer
Regierungsverantwortung spätestens im
Jahr 2025 für Deutschland übernehmen
will der muss klar und deutlich sagen wo
wir Deutschland im Jahr 2030 sind jedes
einzelne Mitglied ist gefragt auch im
Diskurs mit dem Nachbarn mit der
Arbeitskollegin und so weiter
Positionen zu verteidigen und auch für
demokratische
Grundlagen einzutreten jeder einzelne
basiserwartung und Berliner Reaktionen
aber scheinen nicht immer deckungsgleich
in Berlin spaltet die Frage wie man auf
die nicht zufriedenstellende Zahlen
eigentlich reagieren soll wir brauchen
nicht irgendwelche Worte umgetüme oder
ein bürokratischen sprech sondern wir
brauchen einfache Sätze die die Menschen
im Land verstehen
zurück diesmal um die Rhetorik der
Partei dass man das sprachlich auch
vernünftig kommuniziert nicht in den
Wettstreit sozusagen Eintritt wer kann
das sozusagen am zugespitztesten
formulieren bloß nicht den Eindruck
erwecken man würde die AFD kopieren denn
das würde die Wähler wahrscheinlich noch
mehr verschrecken
Einigung oder Streik damit beginnen die
Nachrichten von dir Gundula ja wieder
noch im Tarifstreit bei der Deutschen
Bahn haben sich Konzern und die
Gewerkschaft EVG am Abend einvernehmlich
auf nächste Woche vertagt nach
intensivem Verhandlungen über fünf Tage
sollte heute eigentlich ein Ende gesetzt
werden in vielen Themen habe man eine
Verständigung erreicht über die jetzt
beide Seiten in den zuständigen Gremien
beraten wollten sagte Bahn
Personalvorstand Seiler das Ziel sei in
Sicht
der Bundestag hat gemeinsam mit
zahlreichen Gästen an den Volksaufstand
in der DDR vor 70 Jahren erinnert dabei
wurde auch ein Ton Dokument eingespielt
von Arbeitern eines elektromotorenwerks
im Harz
erstens
freie und geheime Wahlen in ganz
Deutschland
Bundespräsident steinmeier sagte das
Grundgesetz garantiere genau die
Freiheiten die sich die Demonstrierenden
damals gewünscht hätten
des Weiteren hat der Bundestag einem
Gesetz für mehr Tierschutz zugestimmt
mit einem verpflichtenden
tierhaltungskennzeichen zunächst nur für
Schweinefleisch sollen Verbraucher
besser erkennen wie die Tiere gehalten
wurden das Gesetz gilt als Eckpfeiler
der von Landwirtschaftsminister öste mir
betriebenen Agrarreform Umwelt-
die Regierung Marlies hat den
unverzüglichen Abzug der
UN-Friedenstruppen aus ihrem Land
gefordert vor dem Ur in Sicherheitsrat
sagte Außenminister Diop die Truppen sei
nicht mehr in der Lage auf die
angespannte Sicherheitslage angemessen
zu reagieren sondern Teil des Problems
geworden unter den 10.000 Blauhelmen
sind mehrere hundert Bundeswehrsoldaten
ihr Einsatz wurde erst Ende Mai um ein
Jahr verlängert
bei einem Besuch des fliegerhorsts zwei
Jagel in Schleswig-Holstein hat
Bundeskanzler Scholz die Bedeutung des
großmanövers eher Defender betont die
seit Jahren geplante gemeinsame Übung
der NATO-Staaten mit weiteren Partnern
sei ein Zeichen der Geschlossenheit der
NATO und ihrer Verbündeten an diesem
größten luftwaffenmanöver seit Gründung
der NATO sind etwa 10.000 Soldaten aus
25 Ländern mit 250 Flugzeugen beteiligt
es dauert noch eine Woche
während des Besuchs einer afrikanischen
Delegation hat die ukrainische
Hauptstadt massiven Raketenbeschuss
erlebt laut Außenminister Kollege waren
es die heftigsten Attacken seit Wochen
bei den Beratungen von Südafrikas
Präsident Drama Posa und anderen
afrikanischen Staatschefs mit Präsident
selensky Bestand dieser auf dem Abzug
der russischen Truppen morgen wollen sie
mit Präsident Putin in St Petersburg
sprechen auf dem dortigen
Wirtschaftsforum erklärte der Kreml-Chef
erneut die ukrainische Gegenoffensive
habe keine Chance
ja und auch wenn der russische Präsident
das sagt die vor kurzem gestartete gegen
Offensive der Ukraine geht ja dennoch
weiter insbesondere im Süden gab es in
den letzten Tagen ein paar Erfolge
aktuell soll sich das Tempo allerdings
verlangsamt haben wohl auch wegen des
russischen Widerstand sagen ukrainische
Militärs und Präsident selensky
der nannte die Situation an der
frontschwierig schwierig ist es auch für
die die nicht an der Front sind jedes
kleine Lebenszeichen ihrer kämpfenden
Angehörigen gibt ihnen aber halt und
Hoffnung Alicia jung
es gab Zeiten da hat Anastasia kolonenko
ihren Mann Serie alle zwei Wochen mal
gehört er kämpft an der Front im Süden
der Ukraine aktuell ist es ein bisschen
besser und sie versuchen täglich einmal
kurz zu telefonieren
jeder würde sich Sorgen machen wenn der
Mann beschossen wird und er tagelang
nicht erreichbar ist macht man sich
natürlich Sorgen
doch will die Ukraine hier zurückerobern
Anastasia muss daran glauben dass es gut
geht ist darf nicht hysterisch werden
sonst spürt er das auch durch unsere
Verbindung du willst auch nicht an das
Schlimmste denken sonst ruft man das
herbeiführer
während die Männer an der Front kämpfen
sind es die Mütter Frauen Töchter die
versuchen von saporisha aus zu
unterstützen in der Hilfsorganisation
von Ludmilla pecorina besorgen Sie
Medikamente knüpfen Tarnnetze 5 schaffen
Sie an einem Tag 170 sind aktuell
bestellt Ludmilla selbst hat vier Söhne
an der Front
welche Mutter könnte sich jemals daran
gewöhnen jeden Tag mache ich mir sorgen
jeden Tag warte ich auf gute Nachrichten
viele Menschen in saporisha wünschen
sich natürlich Erfolge fürchten aber
auch um das Leben ihrer Liebsten die
dort kämpfen die Front ist von hier
nicht mehr weit
ja wir sollten ein Gleichgewicht finden
zwischen es sollte eher langsam
vorangehen damit es nicht am Ende
tausende Leben unserer Helden kostet in
der Stadt bemüht man sich um Normalität
Soldaten kommen für ein zwei Tage Pause
zum Luftholen wenn kein raketenalarm ist
sind die Geschäfte auf wenn er auffällt
geht niemand mehr in den Bunker in den
ersten Monaten war es natürlich schlimm
alle haben sich versteckt jetzt haben
wir uns schon daran gewöhnt
so sehr man sich eben an Krieg gewöhnen
kann auch saporisha wurde schon zum Ziel
von Raketen der letzte große Angriff vor
gut einem Monat
anastasiaco freut sich allein darüber
wenn die Telefonverbindung zu ihrem Mann
funktioniert das ist ihr kleiner Moment
zu zweit wie früher
dann sehen wir uns wieder
[Musik]
ich denke bald
Anastasia sagt ihr Mann habe einen
Schutzengel alles wird gut
wir blicken jetzt auf die Wirtschaft mit
Gundula und du beginnst deinen Blog mit
nicht ganz so guten Nachrichten inmitten
der Rezession nehmen die Firmenpleiten
in Deutschland spürbar zu das
Statistische Bundesamt registrierte im
ersten Quartal eine Zunahme der
beantragten Insolvenzen gegenüber dem
Vorjahr um über 18 Prozent während der
Pandemie und in der Energiekrise
schützten noch staatliche Hilfen Sina
meinitz womit rechnen Experten und
Statistiken wie sie die weitere
Entwicklung aus also es wird damit
gerechnet dass sich dieser Trend zu
weiteren Firmen Pleiten im zu Ende gehen
Quartal noch fortsetzen könnte
insbesondere haben die Baubranche und
automobilzuliefer und der stationäre
Einzelhandel stark zu kämpfen die Zahl
der Firmen Pleiten war in den
vergangenen Jahren auf einem
vergleichsweise niedrigen Niveau denn
die staatlichen Finanzhilfen und
Ausnahmeregeln für Insolvenzanträge
haben einige Firmen tatsächlich über
Wasser gehalten und ohne diese
Unterstützung gehen bei vielen nun die
Lichter aus zumal die Herausforderungen
für die Unternehmen gewachsen sind durch
gestiegene Produktionskosten mehr
Personalausgaben und ein höheres
Zinsniveau obwohl es mehr Firmenpleiten
gibt wollen Experten aber nicht von
einer Insolvenzwelle sprechen und im
Gegensatz dazu ist der DAX in dieser
Woche auf Rekordhöhen gestiegen wie
erklärt sich diese Diskrepanz also
selbst eingefleischte Ökonomen können
sich das manchmal kaum erklären und
sagen der DAX führt ein Eigenleben
allein in dieser Woche liegt das Plus
bei rund zweieinhalb Prozent heute
erreichte er mit über 16.400 Punkten ein
neues Rekord hoch den Handel verließ der
DAX dann bei
16.358 Punkten die notenbänke haben
getan was am Finanzmarkt erwartet wurde
eine Zinspause in den USA und eine
leichte Zinsanhebung der Europäischen
Zentralbank die Investoren sehen zwar
das Risiko dass die Geldpolitik zu sehr
gestraft werden könnte lassen sich bei
den aktuellen Konjunkturdaten aber nicht
abschrecken im Moment ist die G größer
als die Angst heißt es hier am
Aktienmarkt doch zu viel Gier kann
bekanntlich auch gefährlich sein vielen
Dank an Sina Malitz
die frühere stellvertretende
Regierungssprecherin Ulrike Demmer wird
neue Intendantin des Rundfunks
Berlin-Brandenburg rbb die 50-Jährige
Journalistin muss den Skandal um
ex-intendantin Schlesinger weiter
aufarbeiten die das Amt nach Vorwürfen
der Vetternwirtschaft und der
Verschwendung abgegeben hatte
nachdem hart erkämpften drei zu drei im
Freundschaftsspiel gegen die Ukraine war
auch der em-test am Abend gegen Polen
für die Fußballnationalmannschaft eine
besondere Herausforderung sie verlor das
Spiel 0 zu 1
im Schweizer Kanton Graubünden ist der
seit Wochen erwartete Felssturz
niedergegangen und hat dabei nur knapp
den kleinen Ort Brienz verfehlt die
geröllmaßen mehr als eine Million
Kubikmeter machten wenige Meter vor dem
alten Schulhaushalt der Ort war bereits
seit Mitte Mai evakuiert anders als beim
jüngstenfeld Sturz in Tirol geht in
Brienz nicht der Klimawandel als Ursache
sondern natürliche Bewegungen des Berges
Vorbereitung ist das halbe Leben das war
es jedenfalls von uns es geht aber
direkt weiter mit Matthias hornoff und
den aktuellen Zahlen aus dem
Politbarometer
guten Abend willkommen zum
Politbarometer der Bundeskanzler feierte
in dieser Woche seinen Geburtstag
inklusive Ständchen das Kabinetts die
sonst so streitlustiger Ampel kurzzeitig
vereint im Happy Birthday
politisch ist die Stimmung längst nicht
so ausgelassen und das spielt vor allem
einer
Oppositionspartei indikaten wenn am
nächsten Sonntag wirklich Bundestagswahl
wäre würde die SPD leicht verlieren und
käme offen
19%. die cdu/csu wäre weiter stärkste
Kraft 28 Prozent die Grünen 16 FDP 6
alle unverändert die AFD gewinnt dazu
kommt auf 18 Prozent und damit auf ihren
höchsten Wert überhaupt im
Politbarometer die Linke 5%
. dabei hatte sich die Ampel in dieser
Woche sogar zusammengerauft sich in
einem Spitzengespräch zum heizungsgesetz
geeinigt wieder mal ein Streit beigelegt
nach wieder mal wochenlangen
Diskussionen
inzwischen sind nur noch 41 Prozent
überzeugt dass die Bundesregierung ihrer
Arbeit gut macht 54 Prozent attestieren
ihr eher schlechte Arbeit das ist der
schlechteste Wert seit die Ampel regiert
das eine Regierung von cdu/csu ist
besser machen würde glauben aber
lediglich 26 Prozent 49 Prozent erwarten
da keinen Unterschied 21 Prozent gehen
sogar davon aus dass es schlechter würde
Unzufriedenheit durch die Bank weg so
erklärt sich eine Mehrheit auch den
aktuellen Höhenflug der AFD
dreiviertel meinen sie würde
hauptsächlich gewählt um den anderen
Parteien ein Denkzettel zu verpassen
nicht in erster Linie wegen ihrer
politischen Forderungen
kommen wir zu unserer Top Ten also der
Bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
Politikerinnen und Politiker nach
Sympathie und Leistung so viel vorweg
von Top Werten ist unsere Top Ten
derzeit weit entfernt die
Beliebtheitswerte bleiben oft sehr
niedrigem Niveau
auf der Skala von +5 bis -5 kommt Alice
Weidel wieder in die Liste und ist
Schlusslicht -2,5
davor Sarah Wagenknecht -1,3 etwas
besser Friedrich Merz -0,5 sein
schlechtester Wert seit er Parteichef
ist so wie Markus Söder beide
verschlechtert
Robert Habeck mit zu gewinnen minus 0,4
Christian Lindner mit Verlusten minus
0,3 Karl Lauterbach minus 0,1 Annalena
baerbock 0,0 beide unverändert
Olaf Scholz hat verloren und liegt jetzt
bei 0,2
Spitzenreiter bleibt Boris Pistorius 1,9
auch er etwas schlechter
überall warten politische Probleme auf
eine Lösung so auch in der Asylpolitik
denn es kommen weiter viele Menschen aus
Krisengebieten zu uns nach Deutschland
aktuell meinen 45 Prozent das
Deutschland das verkraften kann 52
Prozent glauben das nicht noch im März
herrschte da mehr Optimismus damals
sagten 51 Prozent ja Deutschland kann
die vielen Flüchtlinge verkraften
46% sagen das anders
Vene aufnehmen wen abweisen nicht nur in
Deutschland ist das ein Thema sondern
europaweit die EU hat jahrelang darüber
diskutiert und sich jetzt auf einen Plan
geeinigt künftig sollen Flüchtlinge an
den EU-Außengrenzen festgehalten werden
dort sollen ihre Chancen auf Asyl
geprüft werden
die meisten Befragten finden diesen
Ansatz gut 70 Prozent
23 Prozent sprechen sich dagegen aus
unter den Anhängern fast aller Parteien
findet sich eine deutliche Mehrheit für
diese asylreform nur bei den Grünen ist
die Meinung eher gespalten die Linken
lehnen sie klar ab
künftig werden wohl immer mehr Menschen
wegen des Klimawandels ihrer Heimat
verlassen dessen Auswirkungen sind schon
jetzt spürbar auch in Deutschland macht
eine Mehrheit sich Sorgen wegen des
Klimawandels
wenn es um konkrete Maßnahmen für den
Klimaschutz geht dann zeigt sich aber er
Zurückhaltung
37% meinen die Maßnahmen für den
Klimaschutz in Deutschland gehen zu weit
22 Prozent finden Sie gerade richtig sie
gehen nicht weit genug sagen 35 Prozent
der Befragten
wir schauen noch in die Ukraine dort hat
die lang erwartete Gegenoffensive
begonnen die Ukraine will zurückholen
was ihr gehört und meldet erste Erfolge
dass die Ukraine jetzt wesentliche Teile
der besetzten Gebiete zurückerobern kann
erwarten 47 Prozent 39 Prozent glauben
das nicht
der Sommer steht vor der Tür und obwohl
die Jahreszeit ja eigentlich für
Entspannung und Leichtigkeit steht wird
die politische Lage wohl angespannt
bleiben
das war unser Bericht über die Stimmung
im Land die Grafiken und alle
Informationen zu unseren Umfragen finden
Sie wie immer im ZDF Text ab Seite 165
in der ZDF heute App und auf ZDF
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
Umfragen der Forschungsgruppe war ein
zustande kommen Informationen zur
Methodik und zu den Qualitätsstandards
finden Sie unter Politbarometer Punkt
ZDF punkt de
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse das
nächste Politbarometer gibt es dann am
30 Juni nach dem Wetter folgt hier
Comedian till Reiners mit Highlights aus
seinem Programm
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend morgen ist der Tag
dazwischen zwischen dem abziehenden tief
das Gotland anpeilt und die kühlere Luft
auch mitnimmt und dem neuen tief über
dem britischen Inseln das von Südwesten
richtig schwül heiße Gewitterluft
herantreibt so machen sich die Hochs aus
dem Staub das eine zieht hier Richtung
Kroatien und das andere Richtung
Norwegen heute Nacht gibt es noch einige
Schauer und Gewitter die in der zweiten
Nachthälfte dann mehr und mehr in sich
zusammenfallen im Norden bildet sich
Nebel und dem Westen ist es klar der
Wind kommt aus West nordwestlichen
Richtungen und die Temperaturen sinken
zu Meister 14 bis 9 Grad kälter wird es
in der Eifel mit nur fünf Grad die
Höchsttemperatur morgen liegen im Osten
bei 21 bis 26 im Westen bei 23 bis 31
Grad schon am Vormittag gibt's die
ersten Regenschauer hier im Nordosten
und nachmittags Bruder ist dann dort
dann gibt's kräftigere Regenschauer und
Gewitter zwischendurch werden sie aber
die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen am Sonntag
gibt's noch letzte Regenschauer an der
Ostsee und fahren Südwesten wird es
schon schwül heißt da steigen die
Temperaturen bis 33 Grad diese Gewitter
Luft wird sich aber erst in der ersten
Wochenhälfte so richtig bei uns
durchsetzen da drohen wirklich Unwetter
und der Gewitter trächtigste Unwetter
Tag wird wohl der Dienstag werden mit
höchstem Temperaturen zwischen 22 und 32
Grad und mit diesen gewittrigen
Aussichten wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt ein
schönes Wochenende